este vídeo ha sido posible
gracias al surf shark vpn
luego estoy más detalles pero antes
vamos con nuestra historia de hoy
queridos amigos de visual político hoy
vamos a hablar de un tema espinoso porque
nos vamos a centrar en la empresa en
la que está alojada visual política
y que tanto vosotros como nosotros estamos
utilizando ahora mismo hablamos de alphabet
y ya sé lo que pensáis pero alphabet no estáis en
youtube wells y efectivamente estamos en youtube
pero es que youtube forma parte de google
ya su vez google es la principal filial del
conglomerado alphabet y eso significa que no sólo
hablamos de youtube sino también de google maps
de 'google earth' de android de google drive y
de un largo etcétera de empresas mis queridos
amigos de visual política internet es grande y
diverso pero la mayoría de las empresas formas
parte o dependen de cinco gigantes alphabet es
decir google facebook amazon apple y microsoft
estas cinco grandes empresas también se
les llama cafam o las big tex y diréis
pero dónde está el problema por ejemplo si
no fuera porque existe una plataforma tan
grande como youtube visual polític no sería
posible ni tampoco ninguno de los canales que
tanto os gustan y que han empezado con unos
amigos como nosotros grabando vídeos su casa
por supuesto podríamos haber montado una página
web pero quién nos conocería sin un buscador como
google tendríamos que haber gastado miles de
millones de dólares en publicidad para poder
llegar a todos vosotros y eso es impensable para
casi ningún youtuber todo esto es fantástico pero
existe un riesgo os voy a dar un ejemplo a día
de hoy el buscador google acapara más del 80%
del mercado en todo el mundo hay muy pocos países
donde google no sea el motor de búsqueda dominante
uno de ellos es rusia donde están en tablas con
yandex y el otro es china donde está prohibido
en el resto del mundo google es el buscador
principal y cuando digo principal me refiero
a que en países tan dispersos como españa la
india o brasil más del 90% de las búsquedas se
hacen a través de google en otras palabras
podríamos decir que existe un monopolio de
google en las búsquedas y directos pero esto
realmente es un problema pues depende de cómo
lo veamos por un lado google se ha ganado su
posición dando un servicio fantástico creo que
aquí no hay ninguna duda la pregunta ahora es
podría surgir una empresa que les hiciera a la
competencia muchos pensaréis y quién más da si se
utiliza un buscador u otros y solo lo usamos para
para todo el buscador es lo primero que
utilizamos antes de entrar en internet
es decir que si algo no aparece en los primeros
resultados de búsquedas de google podemos decir
que es como si no existiera esto significa
muchísimo poder para google principio este
poder no tiene por qué ser malo pero a
veces puede tener consecuencias como están
antimonopolio la comisión europea multa google
con 2.420 millones de euros por abusar de su
posición dominante como motor de búsqueda
dando ventajas ilegales a sus servicios de
compras esta es sólo una de las muchas multas
que la comisión europea ha puesto a google por
lo que llaman abuso de posición de mercado a
día de hoy google está apelando estás multas
en los tribunales y es que ninguno de estos casos
tiene una respuesta fácil europa dice que google
abusa de su posición de mercado pero google dice
que tanto su motor de búsqueda como su sistema
operativo android son que son suyos y es lógico
que si tú entras en una tienda el dueño quiera
promover un producto sobre cualquier otro por
la razón que sea es más google también permite
que otros productos puedan promocionarse en sus
plataformas como veis hablamos de un debate donde
ni siquiera nosotros en visual político tenemos
una opinión clara y ya sé lo qué pensaréis muchos
y si esto fuera una estrategia de europa para
castigar a una empresa estadounidense pues lo
cierto es que estas batallas legales
no están únicamente en europa atentos
el departamento de justicia de eeuu y 11 estados
acusan a google de infracciones antimonopolio
la demanda acusa a google de usar su enorme
tamaño para monopolizar ilegalmente el mercado
de publicidad generada por el buscador como
podéis ver esta es una demanda muy parecida
a las que ya había presentado europa y lo
más seguro es que el proceso judicial vaya
para años de nuevo hablamos de un debate
donde no hay una respuesta fácil antes de
seguir tenemos que decir que google no es
la única empresa que está teniendo batallas
antimonopolio apple facebook o amazon están
sufriendo procesos muy parecidos pero en este
vídeo vamos a centrarnos en el grupo alfa bet
es decir en google así que la pregunta que hoy
nos hacemos es de dónde viene esta batalla
legal hasta qué punto hablamos de razones
económicas o de simples intereses políticos
cómo funciona la legislación antimonopolio
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes antes vamos a hablar de la otra cara de
internet la cara más oscura como sabéis este
año 2020 mientras todos estábamos en casa
usando internet más que nunca los ciberataques
se han multiplicado desde estafas hasta saqueos
y cómo nos protegemos contra los hackers exacto
con una vpn y cuál es la vpn favorita de visual
político pues ya lo sabéis todos porque
lo decimos todos los meses sur shark vpn
vamos a decirlo claro surf shark es una vpn
fantástica y super segura por ejemplo nos ha
pasado alguna vez que entráis en una página
web ellos empiezan a salir un montón de pop
apps de propaganda esto se llama fishing pues
bien sus art tiene una herramienta que se llama
clean web que bloquea todos estos popup si todos
estos enlaces que pueden ser un auténtico peligro
pero no sólo eso con una única cuenta de surf
shark podéis registrar todos los dispositivos
que queráis el móvil la tableta el portátil
no hay ningún límite de dispositivos y como
siempre tenemos una oferta muy especial para
todos vosotros que seguís visual política
básicamente si usáis el código político tendréis
un 84 por ciento de descuento más cuatro meses
extra totalmente gratis es más podéis probar
surf shark durante los primeros 30 días sin
ningún compromiso en la descripción os dejo los
enlaces y ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
el gran dilema del capitalismo el
capitalismo es un sistema económico
que se fundamenta en inquietud puedas
montar una empresa y sigas un buen
servicio la gente te irá bien si las un
servicio extraordinariamente bueno pueden
llegar a convertirte en prácticamente
el único proveedor de este servicio
realmente esto no se da tan a menudo como la
gente se piensa de hecho en la mayor parte de los
monopolios que existen en el mundo son monopolios
generados por los estados en otras palabras la
mayor parte de los monopolios del planeta son
de empresas públicas por ejemplo en españa
renfe tiene el monopolio de los trenes algunos
servicios postales son un monopolio estatal en
eeuu pero también hay monopolios que surgen
por el propio sistema de libre mercado y como
os podéis imaginar esto entra en colisión con otro
principio básico del capitalismo la competencia es
decir mientras haya varias empresas compitiendo en
un campo los productos irán mejorando en calidad
y en precio si una empresa no ofrece calidad y
buen precio los consumidores se van a otra el
problema si una empresa es demasiado grande podría
llegar a comprar a los posibles competidores por
ejemplo cuando facebook compro instagram
acabo con uno de sus mayores competidores
es esto bueno o malo para el mercado pues hay
opiniones legítimas para todos los gustos y
aquí es cuando hablamos de las legislaciones
antimonopolio y del abuso de la posición dominante
un ejemplo de esto sería microsoft si recordáis
en los años 90 microsoft tenía el monopolio de
los sistemas operativos el 90% de los ordenadores
personales de todo el mundo utilizaban windows
así que la pregunta no era si windows o apple
sino si windows 95 windows 98 vamos que windows
no era un sistema operativo era el sistema
operativo y entonces ocurrió lo siguiente
el departamento de justicia presenta una
demanda antimonopolio contra microsoft por
monopolizar ilegalmente los mercados de software
informático esta demanda de 1998 se convirtió en
la pesadilla de bill gates el departamento de
justicia acusaba a microsoft de competencia
desleal cláusulas de exclusividad ilegales
y también de abuso de su posición dominante
al incluir su navegador internet explorer en el
sistema operativo windows y el resultado fue éste
se ordena microsoft any vivirse en
dos empresas efectivamente microsoft
tendría que separarse en dos una empresa
encargada de los sistemas operativos y
otra del software sin embargo microsoft
apeló y llegó un acuerdo menos drástico
pero aún así bastante doloroso aceptaba que las
empresas de la competencia tuvieran acceso a sus
sistemas ya las interfaces de programación de
aplicaciones durante los cinco años siguientes
hoy en día 20 años después de esta demanda
microsoft ya no tiene el monopolio de los sistemas
operativos apple ha ganado más cuota en el mercado
de la que tenía antes e incluso hay gente que
utiliza más el teléfono móvil que el ordenador
así que entran ahora en juegos sistemas operativos
como android es decir microsoft sigue siendo una
empresa muy competitiva pero ya no es un monopolio
y aquí llega la gran pregunta que os estallará
la cabeza habría ocurrido esto si no hubiera
sido por la intervención del gobierno o tal
vez siempre había habido espacio para nuevas
empresas que le hicieran sombra a microsoft
esto os lo dejo para que los reflexiones pero
ahora vamos con lo que sí podemos responder
de qué le acusan a google cuáles son los
cargos que presentan para acusarles de prácticas
monopolísticas pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
y bold como todos sabéis google es una de esas
empresas creada por un inmigrante sergey brin
es uno de los cofundadores de google
junto a larry page y es de origen ruso
en el año 1995 estos dos estudiantes de stanford
idearon el algoritmo básico de lo que luego sería
google tres años después ya tenían inversores
una empresa constituida bajo el nombre google
inc e incluso su propia sede en un garaje
garaje que por cierto era propiedad de la que
luego sería la ceo de youtube susan wojcicki
por aquel entonces internet estaba empezando
sólo tenía 200 millones de usuarios en todo el
mundo aún así ya existían buscadores como yahoo
yandex walt a vista y un largo etcétera muchos
de ellos incluso se anunciaban por la televisión
y bajo
jaja aunque todavía no existía un modelo
de negocio claro los inversores estaban
convencidos de que internet era el futuro
así que la competencia por convertirse en
el líder de todos los buscadores
era salvaje ahora bien la próxima
vez que pienses que has cometido el
error de tu vida recuerda a excite
lo más seguro es que ni siquiera sepáis de
quienes estoy hablando verdad pues bien a
finales de los años 90 excite era uno de
los portales más importantes de internet
con su propio buscador un servicio de correo
electrónico y un montón de cosas más en 1999
page y brin quisieron vender su google a excite
por nada menos que 750 mil euros al mes así habéis
oído bien ni siquiera llegaba al millón sin
embargo los genios que tomaban las decisiones
en el site declinaron la oferta y no fueron los
únicos porque yahoo hizo exactamente lo mismo
ambas empresas sabían que el algoritmo de google
ofrecía resultados bastante mejores que los suyos
pero con los algoritmos que ya tenían no les
iba nada mal así que para que cambiara algo
ella funciona tres años más tarde excite estaba en
bancarrota para entenderlo mejor tenéis que pensar
en toda la disrupción que suponía google en aquel
momento google prioriza los resultados en función
de lo que le importa al usuario esto puede
parecer una obviedad hoy en día pero en aquel
momento los buscadores priorizaban los resultados
en función de los propios intereses de la empresa
pero no sólo eso google era el
único buscador que sólo servía
para eso para buscar tanto yahoo como
otros buscadores trataban de ofrecer
un todo en uno para que te quedaras en su
web el máximo tiempo posible mnoticias el
tiempo y hasta videojuegos en otras palabras
google ofrecía un producto mucho mejor para
los usuarios y los usuarios recompensarán a
google con su confianza de hecho el eslogan
que resume la filosofía de esta empresa y que
se puede ver en todas sus oficinas es donde vi
es decir no seas malo y no te conviertas en una
de esas grandes empresas desalmadas hecho a día
de hoy google es una de las empresas que mejor
trata a sus empleados si queréis saber lo que es
un desayuno de lujo hacemos amigos de alguien que
trabaja en google porque en vuestra vida habéis
visto un buffet libre más amplio y más potente
lo cierto es que esta fórmula les ha funcionado
hasta nuestros días cuando google salió a bolsa
en el año 2004 sus acciones valían 85 dólares
ya era una empresa equiparable a fort con una
capitalización bursátil de 23 mil millones de
dólares pues bien hoy en día hablamos de un
billón de dólares y si billones en español en
inglés sería trillion y qué es lo que hizo
google para crecer tanto pues como sabéis
hoy en día google es todo un conglomerado
que ofrece todo tipo de servicios tiene el
navegador más usado del mundo servicios
en la nube y por supuesto este servicio
google compró youtube por 1650 millones de
dólares en definitiva google ha cambiado
totalmente como usamos internet y seamos claros
lo ha cambiado a mejor sin ir más lejos youtube
ha conseguido lo que ninguna televisión pública
ha conseguido que el contenido de divulgación y
educativo llegue a millones de personas y ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando todos claro fonseca es
normal que pienses así google literalmente te ha
cambiado la vida no os preocupéis porque ahora
vamos a ver qué problema puede generar el hecho
de que google sea tan grande el abuso de poder
uno no se convierte en una empresa de un billón
de dólares sin ganarse algún que otro enemigo
uno de los primeros fue nada más y nada menos que
francia cuando salió googlebooks el gobierno de
francia se negó a que una empresa extranjera
digitalizar a su patrimonio cultural así que
francia presionó a bruselas para que crearan
una versión estatal de 'google books' europea
y la verdad es que este proyecto ha salido
bastante mal otros enemigos de google son
las empresas tradicionales cuyo modelo
de negocio sale malparado con internet
en este caso tenemos el ejemplo de los
medios españoles contra google news en
2014 el gobierno de españa aprobó una ley por
la que portales como google news tendrían que
pagar una tasa a los medios de comunicación
tradicionales para poder mostrar fragmentos
de las noticias es a lo que google news se dedica
lo que ocurre a continuación y nos sorprende verlo
google cerrará sitio de noticias en españa por
derechos de autor pero hay que reconocer que
también hay casos donde si se puede hacer una
crítica legítima a google existen casos donde
si podríamos hablar de posición dominante en el
mercado y uno de esos casos es google maps que
crea su servicio de mapas en 2005 pero claro
antes de este momento ya había un montón de
empresas que ofrecían los mapas en internet que
tú tenías una página web y querías insertar un
mapa con tu dirección podías contratar a una de
estas empresas y esto lógicamente tenía un coste
pero entonces llega a google y lo pone gratis
automáticamente muchas empresas de cartografía
digital se imputan a la bancarrota años más tarde
ya sin competidores google maps se vuelve de pago
es decir usar google maps en casa es gratis pero
usar la api de google maps para una web grande
sí que tiene un coste económico en este caso la
francesa botín cartografía llegó a demandar a
google maps ante el tribunal de comercio de parís
y diréis por qué pues por lo que se conoce como
dumping es decir aprovechar que eres una empresa
muy grande para poner precios muy bajos durante
un tiempo y arrasar con la competencia también
tenemos el caso de android google compró android
y nc en 2005 hoy 7 de cada 10 dispositivos
móviles que hay en el mundo usan android
en este mercado google también es el rey
y esto significa que puede utilizar todos
estos dispositivos para promover el resto
de sus servicios es decir te compras un
móvil android y tienes el buscador
de google en la pantalla principal
el chrome como navegador por defecto
y google play instalado por defecto
y que tenga otra tienda de aplicaciones
en principio lo podría pasar muy mal para
competir con google solo porque google
tiene en este dominio con android y este
fue precisamente el motivo de la multa de más
de 4 mil millones de dólares que la comisión
europea le puso a google en el año 2018
o algo parecido pasa con google shopping
si compráis un producto en google la primera
franja está que os aparece son los productos
que venden el propio google y por eso
tanto europa como estados unidos están
poniendo tantas demandas a esta empresa
de hecho la demanda del departamento de
justicia contra google es la más importante
en el sector desde el caso microsoft en 1998
además si este caso contra google prospera
también tendrá consecuencias directas para
otras empresas de las big tex como amazon facebook
o apple y diréis que es lo peor que puede ocurrir
pues bien según él pierde lo más fácil sería
ponerle una multa como ya lo hizo la comisión
europea pero en este caso la pregunta es hasta
qué punto una multa afecta realmente una empresa
tan gigantesca como google en el otro extremo
tenemos las propuestas más populistas propuestas
como la de la senadora estadounidense elisabeth
warren elizabeth warren dice que quiere romper
amazon google y facebook esta mujer propone
separar google en varias empresas de nuevo
no sería la primera vez que ocurre algo así el
gran precedente fue at&t el gran gigante de la
telefonía en eeuu en 1984 la obligaron a dividirse
en pequeñas empresas conocidas como las baby first
el problema el problema es que estas medidas
primero violan los derechos de propiedad pero
no sólo es muy probablemente las empresas
que surgieran de la atomización de google
terminarían siendo monopolios en sus respectivos
verticales así que no habríamos solucionado ningún
problema la opción más probable dentro de las que
se están barajando podría ser que eeuu obligar a
google a compartir su plataforma y algunos de sus
algoritmos con los competidores y aquí es donde
llega la pregunta con la que empezamos el vídeo de
verdad es imposible competir con google si alguien
diera un servicio mejor como os podéis imaginar
google dice que si sus abogados defienden que si
las empresas de alphabet han llegado a donde están
es única y exclusivamente porque son mejores y que
cualquiera podría competir con ellos y es probable
que la respuesta la tengamos dentro de muy pocos
empresas tecnológicas como spotify o los
creadores de four night quieren reformar
las tiendas de aplicaciones es muy probable que
varias empresas tecnológicas terminen uniéndose
para crear su propio competidor de google play
y de la app store de apple estas empresas se
quejan de las comisiones que tienen que pagar
para estar en las tiendas de aplicaciones y
tal vez saquen su propia alternativa en este
momento veremos cómo de fácil es competir en
un segmento tan importante como el de los
market place de aplicaciones para móviles
y mientras tanto la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que las multas europeas a google son justas
de verdad fomentan la competencia y la creatividad
o realmente el problema de google es que todavía
nadie ha encontrado la fórmula para poder competir
con su buscador en definitiva porque todos usamos
google podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en
los comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual politics sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribirse
a este canal y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
si se ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto